good afternoon everyone my name is
eileen mcfarland i wanted to start by
thank you all for sticking with us until
the end of the conference i know that
your brains are probably supersaturated
with information and before we send you
off to see Imogen Heap
I just want to deliver for you with some
few more things to think about I'm
currently working on an open-source
project that's meant to promote police
oversight and I'm interested in talking
about the way is that facial recognition
can make this work more efficient I
won't be doing a Q&A however if you're
interested in talking you can catch me
afterward or get at me on slack my
twitter handle is also code that code
and I've put it on every slide I think
it's being cut off so it kind of looks
like code that Cod I promise it's not a
fish joke let's get started
facial recognition is terrifying
numerous studies have demonstrated that
facial recognition is racially biased
this is a photo of joy Bolin Winnie when
joy born Winnie was an undergraduate
student she was using face auto
detection software with a few classmates
who are mostly white and she noticed
that the software could easily pick up
the Faceman the faces of her white
classmates however it couldn't detect
her own face until she put on a white
mask she went on to found the
algorithmic justice league and is now a
researcher at MIT Media Lab she did
research that showed facial recognition
for darker skinned women of color has
air rates as high as 35% meanwhile the
same software has an error rate of only
1% for white men the racial bias as well
as the gender bias in facial recognition
runs the risk of not only upholding but
also intensifying existing systems of
oppression this is a photo from a recent
community hearing on the Detroit Police
Department's greenlight initiative the
green light initiative purports to
identify suspects and violent crime
using facial recognition software
there's been strong community opposition
to this
because facial recognition has been
shown to be less effective in
identifying black people according to
the US 2010 the census Detroit is 81
period six percent black as a result
it's possible that the facial
recognition software could miss identify
many individuals and worsen racism in
the criminal justice system additionally
there is an extreme lack of regulation
not only around facial recognition but
also around how law enforcement uses
this software the New York Times
recently reported that beginning in 2011
the NYPD began using a facial
recognition database in 2015 they began
adding juveniles photos to this database
and it now includes photos of children
as young as 11 this would despite the
fact that children do have certain
protections in terms of privacy and
additionally facial recognition has been
shown to be less effective in
identifying individuals who are younger
because typically it's trained with
adults photos I provided examples of how
the state using facial recognition can
cause harm to vulnerable and
marginalized communities but what
happens when the cameras get turned
around what happens when we watch The
Watcher for the last few months I've
been working on a project called open
oversight which promotes police
accountability through open data today
I'll talk about hi I'm incorporating
both machine learning and facial
recognition into the project to snoop on
to them as they snoop on to us here's a
quick outline of the contents of the
talk I'll explain what open oversight is
both how it works and why it's necessary
then I'll run through our data sources
and how we sort the data next we're
gonna talk about ethical and legal
concerns of which there are many
and then I'll touch on the technical
implementation and the three main points
starting with AWS recognition and then
moving on to face a PID is an open
source tool which I use for both auto
detecting faces and facial recognition
there's going to be a surprise so don't
leave early and
the end I'm gonna get philosophical in
our closing as I mentioned open
oversight is a web app with the goal of
making it easier to report police
misconduct it started in Chicago where I
lived for many happy years and it's now
also active in Berkeley Oakland and New
York City though we do have limited data
for New York City you can see the actual
website I'm at the link on the slide
open oversight comm additionally a group
called open justice Baltimore forked the
source code to create a Baltimore
specific site BPD watch comm again there
is a link on the slide in case you'd
like to see the website I will walk
through the general user flow of open
oversight on before showing a brief demo
in order to do a police misconduct
report in Chicago you need the police
officer's name and badge number
individuals who are affected by police
misconduct often do not have access to
this information
open oversight functions like a
directory where you can search for
officers based on what you remember the
name and badge number or demographic
data then identify them and be taken to
an external website to do a complaint
this is the open oversight landing page
you can navigate to identify officers
select the department in this case
Chicago then enter what you may remember
their name
we have visuals of what the different
rank looks like in terms of insignia and
badge type next select anything you
remember about their identity such as
gender and finally you can identify them
and be taken to an external website to
do a complaint so this is one of my
favorite slides I am a very proud member
of Lucy Parsons labs Lucy Parsons Labs
is a Chicago based collaboration between
data scientists and transparency
activists and we focus on data
liberation as well as civic transparency
such as transparency around police
data and additionally we do a lot of
foil lawsuits
I'll explain FOIA since it's a bit of a
jargony term it stands for the Freedom
of Information Act and it states that
government agencies must give
individuals access to public records
this could include anything from police
rosters to also emails or phone call
records I focus my work on open
oversight let's talk about why open
oversight is a necessary tool from March
2011 to March 2015
28% of police misconduct complaints in
Chicago were immediately dropped without
any action because they lacked
identification information that's 4,000
complaints in total that were not
investigated period this is a statistic
from the citizen police data project
from the invisible Institute the
invisible Institute is an organization
that works to help community members
hold public institutions accountable so
even though I don't have QA there is
audience participation I want people to
try and guess from approximately the
same time period March 2011 to 2015 what
percent of police misconduct complaints
resulted in discipline for an officer
just guess
okay so some of you definitely knew this
step before it's 2% yeah so fewer than
2% of the 28,000 567 police misconduct
emplace filed led to any sort of
discipline and additionally the majority
officers who did face discipline were
suspended for a week or less this is
clearly a problem as promised I'll
discuss where we've got data for the
project both in terms of the rosters and
actual images as I said we do FOIA
requests that's a request for public
records if you're interested in doing
one of these you can look at the link
Lucy Parsons Labs comm slash FOIA a
presentation and we have lots of
resources that will help you get started
I also wanted to highlight a recent FOIA
ruling which is relevant both to our
work and also to anyone who has strong
feelings about Taylor Swift so I know
she's contentious I'm honestly not a big
fan but I thought this was a really
great story so I decided to include it
Rob warden um who is the co-director of
a journalist organization called
injustice Watch recently did a FOIA for
the photos of eight Chicago police
officers the police department refused
to comply with it and they argued that
they had a policy of exempting officers
photos from FOIAs because as they said
citing Taylor Swift in court
she runs facial recognition on people at
her concerts in order to identify
stalkers and they were afraid that
someone might do something similar to
photos of officers I really want to know
who the swifty is in the Chicago Police
Department's legal team just saying I
don't think you can FOIA for it I would
love to know the judge responded you
need to calm down
and then the judge ruled against the CPD
policy of exempting officers from FOIA
requests in addition to doing FOIA
requests we've also in the past scraped
social media particularly Flickr to get
officers photos this is a really great
tactic if you're interested in getting
photos of police officers I particularly
recommend checking out their Twitter
accounts particularly the department
specific account we're gonna return to
this and later demos and in addition to
those methods of obtaining photos we
also allow users to submit photos
directly to the website I want to stress
how much we prioritize user privacy we
don't log any information about people
who submit photos in addition if you
have a particularly high security
submission you can use our secure drop
instance I think it's important to
explain why we don't log information
there is a history of people who
document police misconduct then being
retaliated against by police officers
this can cause people to be afraid to
submit photos or to speak out in order
to build trust with our users we don't
log anything after photos are submitted
they get sorted by volunteers
so the sorting process has two steps
this is a photo of the first step where
we ask a volunteer to check yes or no
whether or not a photo actually contains
police officers volunteers are required
to create accounts and additionally we
do log who sorted which photo if a
volunteer repeatedly misidentifies or
miss categorizes a photo they would then
lose the ability to volunteer after a
photo has been categorized as containing
officers it would move to the next step
in which we ask a volunteer to identify
the specific police officer they can do
this by searching through the rosters
and we also ask that they draw a square
around the police officers face on the
front end we use the JavaScript library
cropper jeaious for this so there are a
lot of things about facial recognition
that can get complicated not only facial
recognition but also machine learning
from both an ethical standpoint and a
legal standpoint I want to discuss these
concerns before I talk about the actual
technical approach we took I'll start by
saying that the uses the u.s. is law
enforcement system is deeply racist
police misconduct and brutality hurt
people of color the most as a result I
believe that making it easier to report
police misconduct can help to push back
on this deeply embedded form of systemic
racism but as I also discussed at the
beginning of this talk facial
recognition has been showing that to be
racially biased is it okay to use a
racially biased technology to help fight
a deeply racist system I struggled a lot
with this question it's something that
I'm still working through as I continue
to work on the project and I think it's
important for me to explicitly state
that my perspective as a a white person
who has never experienced police
brutality and be someone who because of
my race is less likely to get
misidentified by facial recognition does
affect my perspective so I worked
through this concern in two ways both
technically and conceptually so from a
technical standpoint I added safeguards
so that a volunteer will still have to
manually approve each result from facial
recognition if you were at the morning
keynote this is what Professor Broussard
would refer to as a human in the loop
system that means that no facial
recognition result is put into our data
without first having a human double
check and then from a conceptual
standpoint I think we need to remember
the bias is most harmful when it's
coupled with institutional power let's
walk through some hypothetical scenarios
to demonstrate this suppose that someone
is misidentified as a crime suspect by
police's use of facial recognition
technology if they're not able to pay
bail they may then be incarcerated
before trial if they're incarcerated
because they can't pay bail they might
then lose their job and if they lose
their job and they're low-income and
they don't have savings they might then
get evicted this could have extreme
consequences for their life and I'm also
just gonna put in a little plug this is
also why it's good to consider donating
to community bond funds now let's look
at a different scenario thank you for
the claps let's look at a different
scenario suppose that someone who's
affected by police misconduct files a
report and they accidentally file it
about the wrong officer
as shown by the two percent stat from
earlier in the talk it's highly unlikely
that this will have disastrous
consequences for the police officer they
have both legal departments and powerful
police unions to protect them
the balance of power it's not balanced
it's a bit like this additionally for
those who might be considering similar
questions about how to ethically use
both facial recognition and machine
learning I recommend reading a paper
called a mulching proposal I included a
link at the bottom and so the subtitle
of the paper is really telling it's
analyzing and improving an algorithmic
system for turning the elderly into
high-nutrient slurry yeah they don't
hide it
so in this hypothetical scenario the
researchers discuss a group that has
decided to respond to global nutritional
deficits by mulching elderly people into
nutritional slurry and this is a graphic
of the process on the slide so they walk
through the different issues of how to
make an algorithm that accurately
screams people by age and then they know
it's not enough to have an accurate
algorithm if what it's doing turning
people into Soylent Green is ultimately
unethical here's a direct quote
sometimes the problem is not how the
sausage gets made but that they're
making people into sausage
as technologists or as technologists who
expire to be involved in civic tech I
think we need to consider not only is
the tech working but what is it working
for legal concerns so as some of you may
have heard facial recognition has been
banned in certain jurisdictions for
example the city of Somerville
Massachusetts recently banned facial
recognition
additionally San Francisco has banned
all agencies including police from using
facial recognition since this project
started in Chicago I'm going to provide
particular attention to Illinois
specific law Illinois has a state law
called the biometric information Privacy
Act HIPAA for short so the biometric
information Privacy Act states that a
person's biometric data cannot be stored
without their explicit consent if you
violate HIPAA the affected individual
can receive a fine of $1,000 or greater
if the amount equal to the damage caused
is greater than $1,000
so that's a lot of money and I'm doing
this for a non-profit so we're obviously
prioritizing not getting sued and since
a facial recognition scam would include
someone's facial recognition markers
that would actually violate HIPAA which
is part of why we haven't used it before
in the project I do want to note that
there are various machine learning
processes that would not run afoul of
BIP for example auto detection of faces
when you just draw squares around every
face that's completely fine under the
law and additionally I using AWS
recognition to Detective police are
present in a photo is also allowed in
order to comply to BIP
I made a modification to the department
model in our database I added a boolean
field called
is facial recognition allowed this
defaults to false whenever anyone is
creating a new department and on the
front end there is an alert displayed
when a user submits a photo to a
department using facial recognition so
here's a
very brief demo it just displays the
users uh it loaded excellent
so here a user select Springfield they
see an alert because Springfield does
use facial recognition and they can then
submit the photo golden okay let's now
transition to talking about the three
prong technical approach I'll start with
AWS recognition it's an Amazon tool for
machine learning of photos and videos
the detect label feature can identify
objects and photos and then return the
confidence level associated with that
label and the object could be anything
from a police officer to a toy to a
fireman it's interesting to note that
there are likely several or many people
in this room who may have had
recognition used on your photos without
recognizing it without recognizing it
recognition is actually used by multiple
dating apps so tinder uses recognition
for the tinder premium feature and
additionally coffee meets bagel uses
recognition to detect any potential
nudity so the next time that you're
swiping think about that here's some
example of the AWS recognition response
when I used a photo of Wiggum a friendly
police officer from The Simpsons you can
see that there's an array of labels
returned and the associated confidence
level so the label toy has a commons
level of 98.5 seven percent and then the
label with the lowest confidence level
is police at fifty nine point seven one
percent recognition by default will only
return labels where the confidence level
is fifty five percent or greater however
as a user you can set a minimum
threshold and additionally you can set a
maximum number of labels you want to
have returned if any of you are
interested in trying out recognition you
can do a demo through AWS console you
would have to make an account here I
have a demo with a photo from the NYPD
Twitter account which I promised
get back to Twitter so here's the layout
select the photo and you can see the
confidence level associated with
different labels a person is highest but
police is also in there nice this is a
code sample from the views file I wanted
to note that we have two separate pages
for image upload so one is only
accessible to area coordinators they are
volunteers that have gone through more
vetting and hence have greater
privileges in the web app so they can
actually submit directly to officers
individual profiles this means that we
don't have to run recognition on it
because we can trust the photos to
actually have police officers in them
however if someone is just submitting to
the general image submission page we
would run that photo through recognition
and we would also mark that it was
sorted by recognition this is a good way
to track what was sort of by humans and
what was sorted by computers and here is
the actual method of detect officers I
set the minimum threshold to be 90 so
fairly high I want to know that if photo
is not detected to have police officers
we don't discard it it goes back into
the queue to be hand sorted as I
mentioned everything is double-checked
by a human and at the end
unlike line 528 you can see that the
results and labels are compared to a
list of recognition police matches this
includes not only the labels of police
and officer but also military and army
the reason I include these is because
when I was first testing recognition
I found that photos of police officers
in riot gear were frequently detected to
be military I think this is telling
finally I wanted to note that
recognition does include an auto detect
faces feature I'll run the demo as I
explain why I decided not to use this so
I opted to instead use the open-source
tool face API J s because I wanted to
avoid vendor lock-in and also avoid
depending on Amazon for a police
oversight project that being said you
know what I mean that being said if any
of you are familiar with an open-source
tool that can automatically detect using
machine learning if police officers are
in a photo please let me know I'd love
to talk to you afterward alright so now
we get to face API j/s this is an open
source free tool made by Vincent Muller
his github handle is just a dude who
hacks and I also included a link to
their repo on the bottom of the slide
thing that's really exciting about this
tools it can do both auto detection of
faces and actual facial recognition it
is implemented on top of tensorflow Jas
tensorflow Jas is an open-source
hardware accelerated JavaScript library
you can use it to both train and deploy
machine learning models and it's
additionally part of the tensorflow
ecosystem which if you're not familiar
with it it's an endo and open source
machine learning platform that's used
for both developing and training machine
learning models if you'd like to add
face API Jas to your project you have a
variety of options for how to do so it
can be used on the back end with nodejs
or front-end in the browser as I
mentioned before open over site is
Python flask however we do have
JavaScript on the front end so I decided
to just use it in the browser and if
you're using it in the browser there's
either the option of installing it with
NPM and then using a build tool such as
web pack or directly adding the script
from the repo I went for the later
option before showing a demo of the face
detection in action I'll quickly walk
through what's going on underneath the
hood
so once these page loads the
auto-detects phases script will then
load all three models needed for face
api j s the models are SSD mobile net
via one model face landmark model and
then also face recognition you have the
option of either storing these models in
the project itself or hosting them
externally and then making in a call to
wherever they're hosted so SSD mobile
net be one is responsible for auto face
detection it draws squares around faces
and it can also return the probability
of certainty associated with that result
next face landmark would just detect the
actual face landmarks that's basically a
layman explanation of that is it's the
location of different features on your
face like where's your nose and then
lastly face recognition um so this will
compute a face descriptor which is a
feature vector with 128 values that's
used to describe a person's face and by
comparing two different face descriptors
you can see if two photos are of the
same person okay so after the models are
loaded a volunteer can trigger auto face
detection by clicking automatically
detective face and currently I've only
implemented the ability to auto detect
one face per feature however face API
j/s does include the ability to detect
all faces in a photo and that is a goal
of mine to soon transition to that one
step at a time
here's a quick demo with a photo from an
officer in the NYPD you can see that if
the user I'll try to make it fullscreen
yeah so they click auto detect a face
and Allen draws a square on the officers
face
but how to implement the actual facial
recognition this would require you to
have a list of the officers faiths names
and then also a list of URLs to images
you can probably guess this but the more
photos that you have associated with an
officer and also the higher quality that
the photos are the better results you'll
get when a user clicks the run facial
recognition button on the front end that
will trigger face API to call detect
single face on all the available photos
and if no match is found it'll simply
display a message to the user saying
there weren't any matches however if a
match is found it would display the name
of the matching officer and I again want
to stress that the volunteer would still
double check this with a roster search
form it's not automatically completed
gotta have humans checking it okay so a
major question I had when working
through this was where to first
implement facial recognition we couldn't
do it in Chicago because of the
biometric information Privacy Act and
certain other jurisdictions that we were
in we didn't have photos for a high
percentage of the police force and so
this is where we get to the surprise I
have an exciting announcement about a
new location that's currently launching
on open oversight Burlington Vermont
I collaborated with members of
Burlington Copwatch I'll give a brief
explanation of Copwatch because I don't
think it's familiar to everyone a cop
watch is a community group which
observes and documents police activity
the objective is to through presence
prevent any possible instances of police
misconduct through this work they've
gotten photos and videos of a very high
percentage of officers and I also want
to note that because Burlington is a
relatively small city it in turn has a
small police force which is part of how
it was easier for them to get photos of
a higher percentage of officers they'll
soon be launching their own open
oversight instance and they were kind
enough to allow me to use photos to demo
facial recognition for you I wanted to
do it with this photo because you can
actually see the officers last name is
DeFranco it's a parent on the badge so
you know the results legit let's take a
look
so auto detect a face it draws the
square run facial recognition I
apologize I don't think you can see in
the back but it says the name of the
officer is brian de Franco yeah alright
um so in review just to talk about
everything we touched on as I said open
oversight is a Python flask web app the
goals to make it easier to report police
misconduct by providing images of
officers that are easily searchable like
a directory we got the data through FOIA
scraping social media and also accepting
photos from users I'm currently working
on integrating facial recognition and
machine learning in order to process the
photos more efficiently this is raised
ethical concerns and also legal concerns
and the surprise was that Burlington
Vermont is getting its own instance of
open oversight so now the philosophical
closing
Michele Foucault is a European
philosopher who's known for his study of
social control as well as prisons he
discussed the panopticon which is a
prison model that set up like a circle
you can see an image of it there we're
in the center of the circle there's a
watchtower and then on the outside of
the circle there are cells the person
standing in the watchtower can see
everyone in every cell at anytime and if
you're in a cell on the outside you know
that you could be being watched but you
never actually know when it's happened
with increased state and police use of
surveillance technology such as
stingrays which can be used to monitor
text messages at protests automated
license plate readers which you may have
walked by today or the Detroit
greenlight initiative which I discussed
earlier in the talk I fear that we could
be living in a pan Opticon I want to
note that the metaphor is limited the
different groups in society are going to
experience different levels of both
police misconduct and surveillance this
depends on factors such as your gender
race immigration status and religion
even though we aren't all experiencing
the same level of surveillance we all
have the ability to look toward the
center of the pan Opticon we have the
ability to challenge surveillance which
is being observed from above with
sousveillance being observed from below
so I hope that after this talk you can
all think about ways that you too can
help watch The Watcher
[Applause]